deux façades identique ou presque l'une
restaurer l'autre dégradé par le temps
contrairement à la façade est le
pavillon ouest du palais du roi de rome
de rambouillet a retrouvé ses couleurs
décrite avant 1830
les enfants ont pu admirer le travail de
restauration ou comparant les deux
façades du palais qui n'ont pas toujours
eu cette allure le palais du roi de rome
a été racheté par monsieur rassier dans
les années 1830 et monsieur ratier a
décidé de couper le palais du roi de
rome en 2000 a démantelé en fait la
partie centrale de manière à pouvoir
revendre les matériaux et il nous manque
le corps de logis les enfants ont visité
l'intérieur du pavillon où ils ont
observé des portraits meubles et objets
d'art restauré pour initier les jeunes à
la conservation du patrimoine
l'exposition leur a proposé de
construire les corniches en plâtre comme
lors de la phase de restauration le
bâtiment qui est juste à côté
eh ben il est c'est comme ça sauf que là
on a reproduit pareil parce qu'on est
pas tous fini mais sinon c'était comme
ça
l'exposition de restauration est ouverte
du mercredi au dimanche et se déroule
jusqu'au 28 avril